[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHAILEN TULI: Hi, everyone.
My name is Shailen Tuli.
I am a developer
programs engineer
working on Android at Google.
And I'm here to talk
to you about building
great apps for
Android O. Android
O was kind of a big topic.
There are lots of
cool things in O.
And there's a talk later
in the afternoon that's
going to cover many of them.
My talk is going to focus on
a couple of topics, basically,
what you can and cannot do
with regard to background work
in your O apps and what you
can and cannot do with regard
to location gathering when
your app is in the background.
This is going to be a
fairly technical talk.
I'm going to focus on
just those two issues.
And I have a lot of material.
So I'm going to
go a little fast.
So you've been warned.
OK, so why focus on
background so much?
Why focus on background
limits that are coming
in O and other location limits?
Because first, I believe
these are some of the biggest
changes in the platform.
And these are changes
that have really, really
great consequences for
you, app developers.
Because I believe
these changes make
Android an even better
platform for writing apps.
So that's what I'm
going to be focusing on.
I'll talk, of course,
about what the changes are,
what strategies you can
use to deal with them.
I'll talk also a
little bit about sort
of historically how we have
come to this point where we have
to limit what kind
of background work
goes on generally and
specifically with regard
to location, so sort of a little
historical overview of things.
OK, so pretty much everything
I'm going to cover in this talk
relates either to
system health--
basically good ram
management-- or to battery,
to how to get more
battery performant
stuff happening in your apps.
What I'll do is I'll start
with a little overview,
just talk about a few
things that sort of just
give you a sense of what's
really happening in O.
And then we'll do we'll
do a deep dive into each
of these topics afterwards.
So the first thing with
regards to system health
is there is a
limitation now in O
that there will be no started
services in the background.
This is kind of a big deal.
But it really only applies
to started services
in the background.
When you're in the
foreground, there
is no limitation to
started services.
You can keep doing
what you're doing now.
The other system health
issue is that there
will be fairly substantial
limits on implicit broadcasts.
So you can still have
explicit broadcasts.
You can dynamically
register for broadcasts.
But broadcast that
go into a manifest,
there's going to be quite a
lot of limits placed on those.
Again, we'll explore these.
So the question is, when
do all these things happen?
When do you have to start
worrying about these things?
And the answer is, when you
increment your target SDK
version to target
O. Now that may
seem like distant
to some people,
maybe not so distant to others.
But I would urge everyone
to start thinking about this
and thinking about it now.
Because even today,
users of your apps
can go into their
settings of their phones,
figure out how much work
you're doing in the background,
decide if that work is too
much, and essentially curtail
that work.
So like it or not, the
limits on background
work that you can do,
those are here already.
So it's something that
you as app developers
kind of have to deal with.
You'll deal with them
much more substantially
when you upgrade
to O. But you have
to deal with them now as well.
So that's all system health.
So let's talk about battery now.
And that's pretty much the
focus of the changes that
are coming in O have come in O.
So basically, what's happening
is that, for battery reasons,
what kind of location gathering
you can do in the
background is going
to be substantially throttled.
So if you have gotten
used to the idea of having
very frequent updates, for
instance, in the foreground
and in the background,
the foreground stuff
is going to remain the same.
The background stuff
will be quite different.
And so the question is,
when does this kick in?
When do these limits kick in?
And the answer here
is, they kick in now.
For any app that is
running on an O device,
regardless of SDK version,
these background limits
with regard to
location are here.
So this means that, if you
have an app that does something
with location and your
target SDK is N or M or L,
that app may actually behave
quite differently without you
having to change a line of code.
That app, when it's
run on an O device,
is going to start
behaving differently--
could behave differently.
So this is a fairly
significant change as well.
And it's something that,
if you have a location
component to your apps, you're
going to have to deal with.
So these are big
changes, like no
started services, limits on
what you can do with broadcasts,
limits to what you can
do with background.
So the question is,
why are we doing this?
How did we get here?
What's really going on?
So the first thing is,
we're not doing this
because we like being
difficult or we just
like making people's
lives difficult. We're
doing this because this
is, essentially, better
for the platform.
It's better for the users.
The users want you to build
apps that are really, really
performant, that do
really great things
with brand management,
that do really
great things with battery.
The changes that
we've introduced in O
have been a long
time in the coming.
So we'll get to all the
details in a minute or two.
But I'm going to
take a little while
and just talk about how we got
here starting in Marshmallow.
So go back to Marshmallow.
And you remember that's
when we introduce Doze.
So what's Doze?
Just a recap that,
when your device
is stationary, when
it's not charging,
when the screen is
off, essentially,
when it's not being
used, we said,
you can't just go
crazy and do all sorts
of things in the background.
You've got to channel
all your background work
into a very narrowly-defined,
well-defined maintenance
windows.
Because frankly, when a device
is just sort of sitting there,
it should not be doing
really crazy things.
It should be a very
well-behaved, quiet machine.
So that's where Doze came in.
Android M also gave
us app stand by.
And the idea of there was that,
if you have background network
activity, how that
activity was done
was actually
dependent on how much
or how little the user was
interacting with your app.
Again, the idea is, if there's
background work being done,
let's just do this
very carefully.
And in Android N, we
give you Doze Light ,
which is basically like Doze.
But the difference is that
the device is not stationary.
So think of, I have
my phone right here.
It's not on.
Obviously, it's not charging.
But it's moving,
because I'm moving.
And again, the idea was, even
then, you do background work
pretty carefully.
So all of this started off
a couple of releases ago.
And what you're seeing
in O is pretty much
a very natural progression of
what we introduced in M in N.
So the other stuff that's very
significant is, starting in N,
we started paying attention
to some broadcasts
that we felt were excessively
noisy, they were causing system
health problems, thrashing,
very visible jank for users.
And we decided to
curtail what you
could do with those broadcasts.
So in Android N, we said, for
instance, the connection action
broadcast, you could
not anymore listen
for this in the register.
And you could no longer register
for this in your manifests.
And the reason was that it was
an extremely noisy broadcast.
We didn't want to
be waking up apps
to inform about
connectivity changes.
It was too expensive.
Similarly, there were
two other broadcasts
that were targeted in N, and
that's Action New Picture,
Action New Video.
These are fired when
a user takes a picture
or creates a little video.
And so Action New Picture
is actually a great example
to consider when you think
about what the system health
implications are of allowing a
broadcast like that to happen.
So imagine a user
takes out their phone,
takes a photograph.
At that point, there
are, let's say, 20 apps
on the user's device which have
registered for this broadcast.
The system says,
all right, let's go.
Let's wake you up.
Off we go, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
And each of those apps now
wants to do some really great,
impressive things.
Because who doesn't want
to impress the user, right?
And so they start Services.
They start expensive stuff.
And before you know,
the system is saying,
hey, apps 6, 7,
8, I can't really
launch you before I
kill off 1, 2 and 3,
and so on, and so forth.
And so the system is, in
this point, in turbulence.
It's launching stuff.
It's creating stuff.
It's killing stuff,
doing whatever it can.
Heaven forbid the user takes
a second or a third picture,
it goes even more crazy.
So in Android N, we said, this
is no way for an operating
system to be behaving.
You cannot register for
these things in a manifest.
We're not going to be
waking up your apps.
We're not going to go crazy
every time somebody takes
a picture or makes a video.
So that's the
background to that.
Now the location
stuff that we're
going to talk about is largely
driven by battery concerns.
And battery has been a huge
issue for us year, after year,
after year, after year.
In our surveys,
one in three users
say that battery
is the number one
concern for them about Android.
And what happens is
users, rightly or wrongly,
associate location
with battery drain.
And because they do that,
they go and disable location
all together, which
makes all the nice apps
that you guys have written
either not work at all
or they work in a
degraded manner.
This is not good for
the app developer.
It's not good for the user.
It's not good for
Android as a platform.
So this time in O, Google has
taken a very serious approach
to battery management and
targeted background usage
of location as a
primary culprit, which
needs to be sort of
carefully managed
for battery to work well.
All right, so that's
the historical stuff.
One more little segue before
we dive into O elements, which
is that, all through this time,
we're going to be talking about
started services,
implicit broadcasts,
background location.
And it's a good thing
to take maybe a minute
and say, what exactly
is foreground?
What exactly is background?
It's sort of obvious at one
level and maybe not so obvious
at another.
So the obvious stuff, when you
have a visible app component,
when the user can
see your app, when
your activity is
started or resumed,
you're in the foreground.
When you have a widget,
you're in the foreground--
fairly obvious.
When you have a
foreground service,
you are considered in the
foreground-- kind of obvious.
It's a foreground service.
Don't let the service
part fool you.
Stay with the word foreground.
You are in the foreground
with a foreground service.
When you have a bound
service and there
is a client in the foreground
binding to that service,
you are then also
in the foreground.
When you have a content
provider and there
is something that is in
the foreground accessing
that content provider, you are
then also in the foreground.
And then there's a slew of
sort of very specialized
cases, which, if you
read about these,
you will understand, yeah, these
kind of have to be foreground.
And accessibility
service, for instance,
has to perform all sorts of
actions on behalf of the user.
It has to be
considered foreground.
Notification listener
service, app start account
authenticator,
wallpaper service--
you can find documentation
on developmer.android.com
explaining all of
this pretty carefully.
The good news is, in
all of these cases
that I mentioned,
nothing that relates
to background limits in Android
O applies, none of that.
If you're in the foreground,
you can pretty much
do whatever you could do
in any release up till now.
Nothing really changes for you.
But when are you now
not in the foreground?
When are you in the background?
So you're no visible
app component,
so your activity has stopped.
There's no widget.
You are in a
started service that
is not a foreground service.
So that would put you
in the background.
You are in a JobService.
We'll be talking a lot about
JobScheduler and jobs later on.
But when you're in
that part of the code,
you are, again, going
to be in the background.
And when you're dealing with the
broadcast inside your broadcast
receiver, you also, in this
time, are in the background.
And all of these
cases, the background
limits that have been introduced
in O, they will apply.
So it's kind of a big deal.
Trivial apps can do without
dealing with broadcasts,
and services, et cetera.
Most people don't
write trivial apps.
They write mature apps.
Those apps will be
affected by these changes.
So I'm going to
dive into Services
and what's changing with
Services in Android O, lots
of fun stuff.
As I said, this is a
pretty technical talk,
so we'll go deep into this.
From now on, applications
can no longer freely
execute background Services.
So the idea is, we want you to
stop thinking about services
and start thinking about jobs.
Move to JobScheduler or
Firebase JobDispatcher
for the kind of work
that you would currently
give to Services.
Apps that are doing ongoing
work with regard to broadcasts
should also start
thinking about jobs.
Because starting a
service, for instance,
to do something in
response to a broadcast
will no longer be possible.
The idea behind these
changes is fundamentally
that, if expensive work or
potentially expensive work
is being done on
behalf of the user,
the user should
be aware of that.
It should be
visible to the user.
If you are doing things that
cost the user data, battery,
ram, whatever, the user
should sort of say, hey,
I know you're doing this.
I approve.
This is making my app
experience really quite good.
Keep doing it.
We don't want
expensive work sort
of happening quietly
in a clandestine manner
without the user's approval.
So that's the guiding principle
behind a lot of these changes.
So now what happens if
you do call start service
and you're not in
the foreground?
You get an illegal
state exception.
If appending intent
is involved, then you
won't get this exception.
But it still won't work.
You'll get a log warning.
Basically, there isn't a way,
when you're in the background,
to start a service anymore.
So this is kind of a big deal.
I don't know if you
think it's a big deal.
But when I first
found out about this
I was like, whoa,
that's a big deal.
But there are, actually,
some very practical ways
in which this is softened up.
So one of them is that
there is a grace period.
So Services continue
to run on for a while
once you lose your
foreground status.
So take an example
of, you have an app.
The app does some.
The user is using the app.
It launches a service.
The service is doing fine.
And then the user
swipes away your app.
It's gone now.
It's no longer in
the foreground.
The service won't be
killed off immediately.
There will be a few
minutes of grace period
where the service will continue
to run, at which point,
the system will step in and
say, OK, enough of that.
And it will kill
of that service.
But it won't be immediate.
And effectively,
what will happen
in a few minutes is the
service's on destroy method
will be called.
And it will be as if the
service had called stop self.
The system will just
do that for you.
But it's nice that
it's not abrupt.
There is a grace period.
The second is, I think, the
realization that, sometimes
when you are in the
background, your app
is going to want to
respond to certain events.
They may be very
user-visible events.
They may be other
kind of events.
And for that, there is a process
to temporarily whitelist apps,
to temporarily treat apps as
if they were in the foreground
for doing very specific things.
This is probably best
explained with some examples.
So let's say you have
a high-priority cloud
message coming down
to your device that
pierces those restrictions.
And your app now wants
to do something with it.
So we give you a period
of a few seconds--
less than a minute--
whereby you can be
considered foreground and you
can launch Services.
Similarly, if you have an
SMS or an NMS delivery,
you may want to respond to that.
So again, that is a short
window where you are given
temporary foreground status.
And you can respond to that.
And in Android O, notifications
are kind of a big deal.
When you are responding to a
notification action of any kind
and there's a pending intent
involved, at that point,
you are treated as if you
are in the foreground.
So this is sort of a
very pragmatic approach
that the framework
team has taken.
They've said, by
and large, we don't
want you doing expensive
work in the background.
But we do understand that
there are some cases where
you need to do it.
And here's how you do them.
So this whitelisting
process should, in fact,
help most developers
target what they
need to do pretty effectively.
That's our hope.
Foreground services are not
affected by any of this.
So you can have a
foreground service,
have a persistent notification.
The user sees that.
And life is good.
The only problem is
that foreground services
have typically been
done in two steps.
You start a service
in the background.
And then you promote
it to foreground.
The first part is not
going to work anymore.
You can't start Services
in the background.
So there is a new API for
starting foreground services.
Essentially, it does
that two-step thing
and it just does it for you.
We'll talk more about
foreground services
and the appropriateness of
foreground services in a bit.
So a question I was asked when
I did this presentation in India
by a developer, he said, do
you expose any kind of API
where I can tell if it's
safe to start service or not?
No, we do not.
It's for the app developer
to figure out when it is safe
and when it is not safe
to start a service.
Essentially you have to
sort of do your homework
and figure out when you're in
the foreground, when you're not
in the foreground,
and go with that.
So that's the gist
of the Services part.
A couple of other points
to tidy up, bound services
are unchanged.
Because we're thinking
much more about foreground
and background, there are
some sort of semantics
of this that are interesting.
So for instance, if
I'm in the foreground
and I'm binding to one of my own
services, that's no big deal.
If I'm in the foreground and
I'm binding to somebody else's
service and they're
in the background,
then they too will be
considered foreground.
Because a foreground client
elevates their status
to foreground as well.
So these are sort of
things that, as you start
thinking in sort O semantics,
in O terms much more,
will be very obvious.
It's not something
that I taught a lot
about when I was writing code.
So this is going to be a
little bit of an adjustment
as we go into O. All
right, here we go.
A question that's asked me,
what about IntentServices?
You've talked about
started services.
What about IntentServices?
IntentServices
are just services.
They are started services.
Everything I've
said about started
services applies to them
And in fact, this is
kind of a big deal.
So the support library
now has support
for the JobIntentService class.
And that's supposed
to be a replacement.
It could be considered a
replacement for IntentService.
We'll talk more
about this in a bit.
Fundamentally, we
would like to start
thinking that jobs are the
way you want to go about this.
Services, expensive
broadcasts are really
have served us well--
somewhat well-- up till O,
which from now on, JobScheduler,
Firebase, JobDispatcher and jobs
are your real Swiss Army Knife
as you go forward
building your apps.
So that's services.
A lot of stuff are
taken, a lot of changes.
So I'm going to throw more stuff
at you now about background
limits and broadcasts.
So the limitation is
on implicit broadcasts.
And the gist of
it is that limits
to implicit broadcasts
delivered to manifest
defined receivers are not going
to be honored for the most
part.
So at this point,
the question comes,
what is an explicit broadcast?
What is an implicit broadcast?
If you go to Stack
Overflow, you'll
see lots of confusing
answers about that.
And the answer here simply is,
if a broadcast is explicitly
targeted at something, at
someone, at some package,
at some app, then it's
an explicit broadcast.
And you can put
it your manifest.
If it is not, if it's
a general broadcast
that is sort of sent
out into the wild,
it's an implicit broadcast.
And you should not put
it in your manifest.
So take, for example,
action package replaced.
Action packaged replaced, if you
register for this before O in N
and lower, you will have
this broadcast go off
every time any packages
is placed on your device.
That's pretty noisy, right?
Contrast that with action
my package replaced.
In this case, a broadcast
is sent only to me,
because my package
has been replaced.
So this is kind of
a big distinction.
It's not always
incredibly intuitive.
But I think this is
something that developers
will have to think about.
Explicit broadcasts
can still be put
in the manifest, no problem.
Now there are some
implicit broadcasts
that the framework team has
understood need to be allowed.
And if you follow these,
there's a pretty good reason
why each one of these is
permitted to still be put
in O world in your manifest.
So action boot completed,
OK, this fires once.
It's required by apps to set
up jobs, alarms, et cetera,
et cetera.
It's not hugely disruptive.
It's OK.
Action locale changed,
well, your locale presumably
doesn't change a whole lot.
And when it does, it's
not totally unreasonable
that apps will want
to respond to that.
Action headset plug,
now this is, the user
plugs in their headset.
So at that point, there's
a user action involved.
It's not entirely unreasonable
that some app is going
to want to respond to that.
Again, this is not
hugely disruptive.
When you have received an
SMS, you'll want to respond.
This is a very partial list.
The whole documentation is
there our androiddeveloper.com.
And it will explain to you
why all these broadcasts,
while they're implicit, are
still actually completely OK.
The dynamic registration of
for broadcast is completely OK.
Nothing of this has changed.
So you can always use
context or registerReceiver.
And as long as that
context is valid,
you will get whatever
broadcast you registered here.
So that's completely OK.
It's not changed.
The idea is, if your
app is being used,
if there's an active
context, and you
register for a
broadcast, it's not
hugely disruptive for the system
to give you that broadcast.
But if your app is asleep,
that's a different thing.
So that's the way to think
about these limitations that
are being introduced in O.
So at this point,
you're thinking, well,
this is fantastic
for users, right?
Your battery is preserved.
Your system health
is so much better,
no long-running services.
All the noise that was generated
by these broadcasts, that's
pretty much quieted down.
What about me, the developer?
I had all these great ideas,
all these great plans.
What am I supposed to do?
So let's talk a
little bit about that.
What you can do is a
bunch of strategies.
So first, instead of having
long-running services,
if there is some external
stimulus that changes something
in your app or that wants to
change something in your app,
use Cloud Messaging.
It's fantastic.
You can use Cloud Messaging.
If you use high priority,
it'll peer through those.
It'll give you temporary
foreground status.
And you're good to go.
If you use normal priority,
that's still very good.
Because now the operating
system can very judiciously,
carefully, efficiently schedule
the work that you want to do.
Normal priority should
be your default.
You don't want to abuse this.
And you want to
preserve the system
health that comes from that.
Another thing is you can
use JobIntentService.
I'd mentioned that
a few slides ago.
JobIntentService is part
of the support library.
It's very new.
It should be considered a
replacement for IntentService.
And basically, what
it will do, it's
aware of background limits.
And it will just sort
of do the right thing.
In pre-O apps, it will
run context start service.
And in O and beyond
O apps, it will
run JobScheduler.nq for work.
So this is a pretty
good way to sort of
have all that abstracted away.
And you don't have
to think about it.
WakefulBroadcastReceiver
is now deprecated.
The whole point of
WakefulBroadcastReceiver
was that you were
handling a broadcast.
And you kick off a service
or something like that.
You can't do that anymore.
So there's really no reason
to have this sticking around.
And finally-- and this is kind
of an important conceptual
point--
you want the operating
system to be your friend.
All right, so go
back to that example
I gave of somebody taking
a picture, which spins off
the starting off of 10,
15, 20 apps, all of which
are now starting services.
At that point, the
operating system
can do one of two things.
It can either run your app.
Or it can kill your app.
It cannot do anything else.
It will try to run everything.
But when it loses the
ability to run everything,
it will start killing things.
You don't want your
operating system
to be turned into a killer.
You want your work to be
scheduled intelligently
by the operating system.
So for that reason, it's
much better to use jobs.
When you use jobs,
the operating system
can say, all right, 1,
2, 3, I run you now.
4 or 5 are run new.
I run 1 again.
It can schedule
that intelligently.
So you want to go for that.
We encourage you
to use JobScheduler
as much as you can.
And the big topic, you can
use foreground services
for doing all sorts
of great work.
And there are no limits.
So a very big temptation
would be to say, oh, my god,
so much is changing in
O. I'm going to just slap
on in foreground service.
And I don't have to
think about this.
The problem with that is,
the foreground service
has a certain meaning, right?
When I'm listening to music,
when I'm in a fitness app, when
I'm using Maps
and navigation, it
makes sense that there is
a notification to the top
and that it's doing work for
me, even when I'm not actively
engaging with the app.
If that is the case
in your apps, great.
Use a foreground service.
It's a fantastic idea.
But if it isn't,
the users are going
to start wondering,
why the hell there
is this persistent notifications
at the top telling them
that you're doing extensive
work that they don't understand?
They'll probably
either stop it work,
or worse still,
uninstall your app.
You don't want that to happen.
Use foreground services
if it makes sense.
If it doesn't make sense, think
of all the other strategies
that we've outlined
and go with those.
And finally, since O is pretty
much putting you in a position
where you have to
think about background
and what you're doing
in the background,
I think it's a good
time to ask, do
you really need to do
all this background work?
I think there has been a sense
for many, many, many years
now in Android that it's cool to
just spin up something and have
it run forever and
ever in the background.
And the system will
somehow handle it.
Well, now the system is
telling you, no, no, we
don't want to handle it.
We don't want this to happen.
So if we are really
at the point where
we are questioning all this,
it's a good time to ask,
hey, I started doing
all this background work
three years, four
years ago in my app.
Do I really still
need to do this?
The answer sometimes you
will find will be, no.
I don't really need to do this,
in which case, you shouldn't.
All right, fast
segue to location.
So first of all, location
is kind of a huge topic.
It's used in a ton of apps.
In fact, when I
started looking at logs
to see who was using
location, I was surprised,
like, oh, I didn't think all
these apps were using location.
But they are.
And in Android O, all the
limitations on location
are actually very significant.
So let's talk about those.
So again, as I mentioned,
people treat location
as they associate that
with battery drain.
They turn off location.
And your apps don't
work properly.
So we believe this
doesn't help anyone.
We believe that location
should be used wisely.
It should be used efficiently.
It should not be
conflated automatically
with battery drain.
We want people to love
their location apps, right?
So this is where kind of big
changes have happened in O.
And you will see,
while this may seem
a little dramatic
at first, you can
see how much better
an experience
this will be going forward
for app developers.
So the location limits
are that background apps
will receive location
in a very throttled way.
So when you're in
the foreground,
you can pretty much
request location--
I don't know-- as
often as you want.
Let's say you want updates.
You can have location
updates 30 seconds, whatever.
Once you go in
the background, we
will give you location
updates a few times an hour.
That's it.
So this is kind of a big deal.
And this will happen, regardless
of the target STK version.
So on your N apps, your
M apps, your L apps,
and whatever, this will
start happening now,
the moment O devices start
appearing on the market.
You can use batching.
And what that does is it
collects location ever
so many times and then
delivers all those location
data to you in a batched way.
And that's the way that you
can get more data points.
And you trade latency
for more data.
But your data will
still be delivered
only a few times an hour.
There's changes in
O to Wi-Fi scanning.
So we could have an
entire talk about,
what makes location expensive?
What doesn't make it expensive?
But GPS is very
expensive-- super accurate,
but very expensive.
Wi-Fi isn't actually that cheap.
So now the deal is that
no location computation
will be performed when
the device stays connected
to same static access point.
There's no need for it.
Your location isn't changing.
We're going to sort of be
very judicious in making
Wi-Fi scans, because
they're expensive.
And this is good
for a lot of people.
For me, I spend--
I don't know-- at a time,
8, 10, 12, 15 hours at home.
I'm connected to the same Wi-Fi.
Why the hell does
location services
have to compute my
location over and over?
It's not changing.
Similarly, when I'm at work and
I spend 8, 10, hopefully not
15 hours at work, again, I'm
connected to the same Wi-Fi.
Nothing is changing.
Why does location service
have to expend energies
trying to compute my location?
Most people spend a lot of
time at home or at work.
So there's a lot of changes
to Wi-Fi scanning that
actually make O much better.
There's also changes in O
to how Geofencing works.
So it was quite normal up
till O to scan for Geofencing
every few seconds.
And we have now made that
not every few seconds,
but around a two minute latency.
This is sort of vague.
But what we noticed
that, even going from,
let's say, tens of seconds
to two minutes for Geofencing
latency, gave us dramatic
battery performance.
In some devices, it was 10x.
It's a little bit
device-dependent,
so it's not always
going to be 10x.
But we found it to be
really quite dramatic.
So that's another
change that's come.
So this is all, up
to now, everything
I've said about
location is about what
happens when you run
your N app, your M app,
your L app on an old device.
What happens when you
actually start targeting O?
What happens to location?
So the first thing
is, we've always
told you, when you
request locations,
use a PendingIntent.getService.
That's one of the
arguments that you
pass to your location request.
You can't do that
anymore, because it's
O. There is no getService.
Background services
can't be started.
So you're going to have to
have a different strategy.
And that strategy is you use
PendingIntent or getBroadcast.
And then you go and register
an explicit broadcast
in your manifest.
And that will work.
So the targeting of
O is not hugely hard.
I think it should be
fairly painless to do it.
Getting adjusted to
the idea that you
are running on O when
you hadn't planned to
is going to be an adjustment.
And I would urge all of you to
start thinking about this fast.
So what are good
location strategies?
Like, what can you
do as developers now?
Because frankly, with
the location stuff,
these changes are here now.
Sooner or later, O devices
are going to start showing up.
And people are going to start
running your apps on those O
devices.
And then they will notice that
location works differently.
So a very good strategy,
instead of having
long-running services or
expensive and very fast
location updates
in the background,
is to start using
Geofencing much more.
We have generally found that
people use Geofencing less
than we would like them to.
Geofencing is very, very,
very supremely optimized for
performance.
So for instance, if I have
a geofence around the Krakow
airport, and I have a
geofence around the airport
that I will be flying
to in a couple of days
in San Francisco,
location services
knows that there is no
chance that-- there's
no reason for it to
expend any cycles trying
to track the geofence
that's in San Francisco.
I'm not there.
But it also knows, I'm
actually not that far
from the Krakow airport.
So it will very
carefully and judiciously
monitor that geofence.
So a lot of the use cases
for location updates
involve updates around an area.
When am I near home?
When am I near a restaurant?
When am I leaving a place,
et cetera, et cetera.
And Geofencing can be
a huge, huge asset.
So please use it
as much as you can.
Use batching.
So I promised I'd talk
more about batching,
so I'll do that now.
Essentially what
you're doing is,
when you're in the
background, you're
only going to get updates
a few times an hour.
But you can get more
data points, as long
as you're prepared to give up--
the trade off is with latency.
So here, you look
at this code map.
So you create a
location request.
You set its interval
to be 10 minutes.
So you say, give me location
updates every 10 minutes.
And then you say, but deliver
them no later than 30 minutes.
So in a normal situation,
what will happen is,
you will get three location
data points every 30 minutes
in this kind of a case.
If you didn't set
the max wait time,
you would not get batching.
And therefore, you would
miss out on data points.
Another very, very
important location strategy
in the age of O is to get
your location passively.
So what are we
talking about here?
Basically, location is
computed on a device basis,
not just on an app basis.
So when your app is
in the background,
and therefore getting fairly
infrequent location updates,
another app may be
in the foreground.
It may be a mapping app.
It may be some other app that
gets location updates quite
a lot.
Location services,
free of charge,
will make that stuff
available to you,
the data points available to
you and to any other app that's
in the background
and wants that data.
So this kind of opportunistic
location gathering I think
is extremely good.
We believe it's under-utilized.
And we would like developers
to use it much more.
So here's an example
how you can do that.
Again, you create
a location request.
You set the interval
to 10 minutes.
You set the max wait time
for batching to 30 minutes.
But then you set the
fastest interval to,
let's say, two minutes, meaning,
if I'm in the background
and anybody else is
consuming location
data, every couple of minutes,
let me know about that data.
And given the sheer number
of apps that use location,
there's a pretty
good chance that when
the user is using their
phone for something else,
they will be gathering
location data.
And then you can
have it for free.
So that's a very
important strategy.
I would urge all
of you to use it.
While you're doing all this,
because of these changes in O,
we're putting developers
in a position where
they kind of have to
rethink their location
strategies from scratch, right?
If you're going to
do that, you might
as we'll rethink them
for pre-O apps also.
If you're running an N app,
or an M app, or an L app,
that too could use from
the same principles
that we are putting
forward in O and become
more battery-efficient.
So why wait?
You can start making
things better now.
So fundamentally, location is
expensive in one of three ways,
related to frequency,
latency or accuracy.
So O is saying to us,
on the frequency axis
it's saying that, when
you're in the background,
you need to not be so frequent.
You can implement that now for
your N apps, for your M apps.
Again, latency, sometimes you
want the real-time experience.
But sometimes it's actually
OK to wait a few seconds
before you get the location data
that has been computed for you.
So use batching, like
we just talked about.
You can do that now.
And if you're using
a geofence, you
can use a responsiveness time.
And the more you give it, the
better your battery performance
will be.
You can do all these
things now for your apps.
And when you're at it,
I mean, O isn't really
dealing with accuracy that much.
If you're rethinking everything
with regards to location,
you might as well also say,
do I really need high accuracy
all the time?
Maybe I can use a balance
power accuracy, maybe no power.
There are a lot of options.
You can read our
documentation on this.
Do I need the best,
greatest, most expensive
location updates all the time?
Probably not.
And finally,
foreground services.
You can go right ahead
and just completely
bypass all these
location limits in O
by running a foreground service.
But you just have to make
sure the user will really
approve of that service.
Otherwise, they will get
annoyed with your app.
And they will
probably uninstall it.
Don't want that.
That's basically
it-- a lot of stuff.
I'm around.
If you have apps that you think
are going to be now struggling
with some of these O limits,
please come and talk to me.
I'd love to hear your story.
And happy coding.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]